hey everyone it's Mich Volos from order
flows.com here and this is the
orderflows market analysis for uh June 6
2017 and a little bit of uh June 7th
it's it's about 4:00 a.m. Chicago time
right now as I'm recording this and you
know I'm back from my vacation I'm just
getting back into the swing of things
right now actually you I had a nice
break nice family vacation we went to to
uh Disneyland in Hong Kong um for my my
my son's birthday and you know so if I
haven't replied to everyone's email you
know I'm give me time I'm getting to
everything um so you know it's always
nice to take a break from the markets
but you know you shouldn't just you know
come right back the day after day or two
after your vacation and just start
trading away um you know get yourself
back into the mental mode you know uh
mental preparation is a big part of
trading you know just as is in sports
you know everyone thinks oh you have to
have skills you also have the right
mental ability and you got to be in the
right mental space mental space mental
Place uh you know to to trade properly
just as you know you would for you know
if you're a doctor or you know you're a
lawyer or if you're a professional
athlete you know you got to have the
right mental attitude coming into the
market so um before I jump in brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures training
contains substantial risk and it's not
for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial na security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not indicative
necessarily indicative of future
results tools I use in this presentation
are the orderflows trader volume
footprint chart which you know allows me
to read what's happening in the market
and you know I I create these videos so
that you can see what I'm seeing and and
try and follow along and understand and
the Delta scalper is a tool that I you I
use a lot um Delta is is part of
orderflow which is basically the net
difference between aggressive buyers and
aggressive Sellers and it's very
revealing in a lot of points in the
market so let's uh jump in First Market
we'll talk about today are the
bonds okay so we made this high this is
yesterday this is the six we made a high
about
and there's nothing special about this
High you do have a Divergence you do
have a price rejector then you got Delta
scalper a little bit later um point of
control but you know this was
interesting down here 820 Delta scaler
given a cell and it goes right into a
three in a row cell but you know you've
already got your your signal up here
three in a row before the three in a row
you got the Delta scoper giving you the
cell and you get a nice move lower now
you come down so you got three in a row
and normally how I like to trade the
three in a row is look for the green bar
after ratio ratio ratio look for a pull
back between the two points that control
between this bar and this bar and you
get it the only problem is you got a
bullish ratio here and then another
bullish ratio here and where's your stop
going to be it's going to be around the
point of control or even the high of the
first bar so you know that three in a
row failed cuz you got another ratio
here so now you got three in a row going
up you got three in a row going down but
really you the way what how you're
supposed to look at a three in a row is
you got red bar you ratio ratio ratio so
red red red and then green this bar here
with the ratio of 540 should be red the
fact that it's not red is not a good
sign I'm not going to wait up here for a
red bar to appear then the market to
sell off this is the warning signal that
this trade is not going to work out
despite the fact that you've already got
a bullish ratio here then you get
another bullish ratio in this bar that's
already you got two signs you got two
bullish ratios and you got a green bar
the market is still going up it should
be a red bar here for it
classically how it should look um
classically optically rather that's how
it should look you should have red bar
Red Bar Red Bar ratio ratio ratio green
bar and then Red Bar here okay but you
don't get it now here you got so you can
then all so you got bullish ratio going
up bullish bullish bullish three in a
row ratios green green Green you want to
see a red bar here which would be the
opposite of this you got green here so
here you got three Reds here you got
three greens but here you got the green
bar here red red red then green I got
green green Green then green this red
bar ideally should be should be right
here for this Market to go higher it
doesn't it just sort of goes sideways so
again you know this three in a row is
not going to give you the entry because
you're going to be looking you know
between the points of controls here so
somewhere around this uh 02 level should
be your entry but it's not it doesn't
even pull back there so you can't even
get the entry that you want whereas here
you got ratio ratio ratio entry between
these two point of controls here in here
you get it on this pullback but then it
just pulls back some more and stops you
out but really you shouldn't even let
this Market go to stop you out because
the sign to get out is right here this
should be the red bar and it's not red
it's
green and then later you get this nice
setup here um you know this is just
before the the cash Clos at 2 p.m. and
you got some aggressive buying here then
the market just falls off boom sells off
quite nicely you got a nice single print
a bearish ratio right here and the
market drops off now 5 years gave uh
some very interesting um trading
opportunities yesterday or
Tuesday and again we had our high right
around the same time 628 point of
control in this bar up near the top you
got Divergence just like you had in the
bonds but this bar here we got a very
you ratio bonds low which is very
bearish point of control right at the
top selling a balances on the way down
so you know there's some volume up here
stopping this move higher this is this
bar alone by itself to me is very
bearish we sell off we make a nice move
lower you get down here yeah you got you
got this Delta scalper excuse me Delta
scalper given a buy it's a dogee bar you
know take it for what it's worth um you
know again I
I yeah I know this bar open and Clos
right at this this level here where the
the volume is 2398 vers
2396 um you know it's got big strong
positive Delta you know can you take it
I said I I don't you know the reason why
I'm I'm Heming and ha about this one is
because I'm not a big fan of dogee bars
and in the order flow and I tend to shy
away from them but it is giving you a
buy here I don't want to say yeah it
gave you this buy you know and Mike
always talks about ignore DOI bars but
you know it's got a big strong positive
Delta as well as well so again I'm not
sure you know if I'd be interested in it
or not but anyway you get up here single
print strong negative
Delta and nice a nice move lower to a
single print down here bullish ratio
nice buying and balances on the way back
up to up here another single print now
this is that area right here that you
have this six lot traded you had a
bearish ratio 532 now remember that's
that area right here where you had the
point of
control excuse me it's not take off the
high of the
day and what you're seeing is you're
hitting this it's sort of this double
top you hit this high that you had
earlier a swing I'll say it's a swing
high but it's it's an important High cuz
you know there was stopping volume there
earlier you hit it what do you do you
react you come off a little bit go
sideways before selling off going into
the evening session where you sold off
some more I'm not saying yeah we I'm not
saying that yeah You' sell it here and
then hold it all the way into evening
session where you trade all the way down
to what is that 13 and a
quarter you got a uh bullish
ratio and a Divergence but um
you know for me this this was a nice a
nice opportunity here you know you got
the bearish ratio right off the high of
the day you know single print price
rejector kicking off so you this Market
it went literally from uh where is it
price rejector low on the swing low to
this price rejector high and he came off
one
sideways
now the other interesting Market is Yen
Yen's been a nice Market uh
a nice mve in Market uh recently I say
recently I mean this
year so where are we here this is this
is where we are right now it's about
4:18 in the morning you know we got a
bearish ratio with the Divergence and
you see we're starting to come off a bit
you know we'll see where that one goes
um but I remember looking at it this
morning here this was a nice Move This
was um just around midnight you hit this
low you got a rati show Divergence and
you literally trade from your low
uh 9125 A2 right up to your high and you
even make new highs up here all the way
up to
9160 um but you went you know from 9125
and a half and all the way up to 9150
but anyway I mean that was that was this
ratio
with the Divergence now go back during
the the normal regular day session here
let's go back here time this is 6:00 you
go earlier so you know 628 also that
same time you had the highs in the bonds
in the uh five years Divergence price
rejector but here you got ratio with the
Divergence and what happens Market sells
off you got this imbalance here I'm not
too concerned
about this double top here nine lots and
two lots I like the back that trades
less the second time around we do sell
off
um okay then you get down here single
print bullish ratio point of control
near the bottom of this bar it's one of
these uh hammers
okay now there's not a lot of
candlesticks that I like to look for but
I do like Hammers and stars okay and
then next bar Delta scoer kicks in and
what happens you start this nice Rally
from the know the 9132 area boom all the
way up to the new highs up here
you get up to
9159 but you know 9132 up to 9152 easily
Delta scalper coming in right here off
the high you got a Divergence no ratio
ratio in the next bar and the Delta
scalper um you you get short gives you a
nice little move lower it's not a
monster move you don't go from your high
to your low like when we went from your
low to your high but it's giving you a
decent move um you know you can't expect
every move to go from your low to your
high back down to your low if the market
doesn't move that way it rallies from a
low up to a high pulls back you know 50%
30 30
uh 30 whatever percent and so on and
then you know you start working your way
back up boom you make new highs here
again Divergence with the ratio
afterwards at a new high and boom it
just Falls over again from this you know
the 9150 area all the way down down down
you don't get back down to your lows but
you get back down to 9130 area does
start to Rally you get this I'm not too
concerned with that going into the close
then obviously I talked about what
happened um later
there now the other interesting Market
um I'll throw in soybeans really quick
um I'll talk about buns but I also throw
I'll talk about soybeans just to sort of
mix it up a little bit I don't want you
guys thinking I'm you know stuck on uh
Financial products or something but
interesting thing again yeah again I'm
recording this it's sorry it's like 5:
in the morning Chicago time is it no 4 4
in the
morning still out of it but again you
know I talk about this a lot Point
control at the extreme here you got
Point control at the top this is an
evening session this is 8 811 last night
you got some volume up here you got a
ratio that you like Point control near
Top Delta scalper in the Mix Bar and you
know and look it's not a big move I mean
it's soybeans you're not going to get
necessarily big moves every night but
you know it's giving you a sell signal
here a sell signal there trying to go
sideways to a little bit lower I mean
we'll see it's just been going sideways
but still you know turning points you
know that's what you want to be finding
in the markets turning points you know
it's nice to get it up here it's better
than getting it in the next bar again
I'm not trying to always pick tops or
bottoms but you know what I'm looking
for rather is when the market is telling
me we're making a top okay or we're
making a b B and you know react
accordingly so again you know just as I
was talking about this here during the
day session yesterday one o00 now be
careful trading you know beans you know
at 1:00 because they close about 1:5 and
if you got any sort of issues with
connection you know next thing you know
you're have a position on the beans and
the Market's closed and you got to wait
till 7:00 um to get out of it you know
generally it's not going to be a
problem you know it's want I say not
problem I mean it's the Market's not
going to get Gap up you know limit up on
you or anything like that I mean it can
but the odds of that happening are very
very minute um I have I can't remember
the last time I saw beans Gap up limit
up on the
reopen um but anyway I don't want to say
that and then it happens and my then not
going to happen and I'll still get
people complaining about it but anyway I
mean I'm speaking of 20 years of of
trading these markets and you know 15
years of trading the stuff on the real
so anyway um again you ratio point of
control at the top and you got a nice
sell
off point of control at the bottom with
the green bar with a bullish ratio
Market yeah it's not a great move but
it's you know it's a decent move you
could get easily um one two three four
four ticks you know that's it's a 50 50
Buck move on a one lot um not every move
is going to be you know the the 10cent
move but um so anyway going back again
8:30 is 8:30 is the reopen here we
are yeah the these highs here you got
Divergence no ratio here you don't have
a ratio you don't have a
Divergence um Delta scalper given a buy
here okay it's sort of in this area
where you've been trading sideways again
you know it's it's a Delta scalper buy
going up towards the highs probably you
know take it for what it's worth um I
prefer Delta scalper sells up near the
high and Delta scalper buys near the low
because Delta scalper is ideally going
to be you know helping you find um when
fine demand shifts you know so if you're
already in a demand driven Market the
market is going up then you get Delta
scoer giving a buy it's probably not
going to be very effective but you know
I like this this one it failed though um
you know I'm not going to not going to
hide it this is Delta scoper given a buy
that didn't work
out
um here you got it but you already have
your move here that you could be taking
so you know that was yesterday in the
beans so there's some again there's some
decent opportunities in the beans you
know a couple of them didn't work out
but a few did as well um crude oil look
at crude really quick cuz that's the uh
screen shot I took of the
uh of the thumbnail so we'll just go
back here to the morning so again you
know 3 in the
morning 3: in the morning Chicago time
yesterday
66 uh 2017 June 6th I close this down I
was looking at this but
um got the swing low Delta scoper given
a buy right here this
47 you know 20 area and what do you do
you you make a nice move up to the 474s
Delta scoper give a sell signal there
you come
off about
the 15 20 cents rally back up a little
bit don't get past this High um sell off
some more
now you got you know ratio ratio ratio
but you got this red bar in there so
again I'm not too concerned with any
taking any trades around there you get
the uh Volos U-turn given a sell
here um okay then it started to get got
interesting when the US opened you know
7:30 you got a sell right here Delta
scaler sell Volos U-turn right ahead of
the Delta scalper and you know did it
sell off I mean sold off from the 47 you
know 28 area 26 area down to the 12 Area
15 area so it's a little bit of a move
again you get another sell signal up
here with the Volus U-turn so you know
you had one here you got one here that's
nice buys though were there
no yeah you
so but anyway uh go back here where was
I okay so that you again giving you a
sell
there sell here this one doesn't work
out just go sideways and then you got
some buying imbalances selling
imbalances going on again this is 855 we
had some stuff coming out there Delta
scalper giving a buy here just sort of
goes sideways on you
unfortunately um then here this was the
nice move right off this low swing low
you got a couple of things one you got
the trans Vol transition and the Delta
scalper giv a buy at the same time and
you're going from you start start seeing
some nice buying imbalances coming in 2
200 127 right before all that happens
nice one here 420 206 but really this
bar is is the bar you want Delta scalper
transition again from the 4718 4720 area
boom straight up straight up all the way
up to the 4760 areas right up towards
the high he didn't hit the high he got
within a tick of the high got a cell in
the Delta scalper but it's a green bar
so I'm not interested in it just sort of
go sideways any need do make new highs
I'm not saying you would held it from
4718 all the way up to you know 40 um
you know 48 bucks or anything like that
then you start getting a delta scop or
sell here but again it's the green bar
you don't want to be taking sells on the
green
bar
um Divergence no ratio no ratio then
here you get another Delta scalper giv a
buy but again you know it's it's you're
right up off your highs you come off a
little bit you know but you know do you
want to trade it going to new highs
again again it's up to you you got a
delta scul or sell right here though
didn't really work out it comes right
back with the Vol U-turn here that's
what this black one is got the buy here
goes starts going up again new
highs new highs this time it's already
3:00 um start coming off Delta surge
here U was there anything interesting in
the evening session going into the
morning not
really it's just sort of going sideways
here most of the morning I mean did have
Delta scul or buy right off this low it
didn't work out just went sideways on
you fortunately um that one just didn't
work out and so the last next market
I'll talk about I'll talk about Euro
currency I'll talk about buns let me
find my Euro currency
here I still got b a sore throat I just
haven't been able to shake this thing
it's I've been to the doctor I came back
I also went to the doctor
um everyone in my family got sick on
this vacation as well which kind of was
kind of a bummer but um we still had a
lot of fun so uh where are we here so
2:30 in the morning you got a ratio with
the Divergence Delta scalper in the next
bar but you know really you can be
buying off this here and you get a nice
move up from uh
5253 all the way up to 6263 Delta
scalper gives a Sell Here comes off to
the next bar just sort of goes sideways
hangs around a bit not really doing
anything again it's a little early in
the morning um you know you do have a
Divergence there you got a stack buying
and balance here takes a while for the
market to finally turn around and go
back up it's not until after the fifth
bar um I say fifth bar you got your
stack buy balance bar one bar two bar
three bar four bar five really by the
fourth bar I really be losing my
patience already with this trade
although it's happening pretty quick
this is 6 27 28 29 29 30 the next one's
33 you also so at least these bars are
happening pretty quick I mean last thing
I'd want is you know this stack buying
IM balance to happen 10 minutes later
this bar another 10 minutes after that
this bar I don't mind it if it's
happening pretty quick at least I know
the Market's moving um in this case it
it made the move
up which is what you like again stack
buying and balance off the low I'd
rather be taking buying and balances off
the lows and selling the balances into
the lows um then here you get the stack
selling a balance again it's right
around your opening price always
hesitant training around the opening
price when we sort of come back to it
later in the
day um then here you got Delta scalper
given a sell here again but it's it's in
this area where you're sort of going
sideways is it going to be very
effective probably not you know I like
taking Delta scalpers after a move up
and get the sell I like that or make a
move down and then get a buy to go back
up I like that rather than sort of in an
area that you're trading sideways around
um then later we do sort of you know
work our way back
up um there's a Delta scalper given a
buy given a sell here but it's not a
green bar so I'm not really interested
in it um you you got some trap Traders
up in here even in this bar you can see
them do come off a little bit then you
get down here it's only 9 in the morning
at this point Delta scalper given a buy
here um here you have a point of control
right at the bottom of this bar bullish
ratio Delta scalper in the next bar and
you shoot up you go from you know the 75
area all the way up into the mid 80s um
just sort of go sideways sideways
sideways another Delta scalper bu into
you know it's it's far enough off the
high I again if if it was happening
where this stack buying imbalances I
might be more concerned but you know
it's happening here after a little bit
of a move lower I don't know it's it's
up to you if you want to consider this
closer to the high or not I I think this
is farther away of far away from the
high that you can action it then you
sort of going in here and then uh again
this was this morning or overnight it's
around midnight here he Delta scalper
given a buy you see we got this nice
move up here did come back down later
about 2:00 when Europe opened you got a
bearish
ratio um but again I'm not looking at
that now you come down in here I think
it was this Market where was
it nothing in this bar it's it's
Divergence but no ratio that I like no
ratio the next bar um you sort of go
sideways then you start popping higher
Delta scalper gave a sell here but to me
this is this is what I consider close to
the low right here I so I'm not really
too interested in that but again that
that's me if you know people like to
take every single signal they get but
you know take it in context of the
market so we go up okay so let's think
of the Japanese Yen actually where we
had hit the low and then you know there
was some nice indic ation in the order
flow um you got up
here um stack buying
imbalance you know red bar right after
was not a good sign you do pull back
down to the low of this bar you know to
me this that's just a little bit too too
much heat especially if we were to get
past this um this low here we have the
79 and 39 if you were to trade below
that forget it stick a fork in that I
would expect the market to go much lower
but didn't it traded right down to that
level uh before going higher uh which is
where we are right now at
82 so lastly I'll talk about the Buns
really quick buns were interesting
yesterday even the day
before but um again um and this morning
also some some interesting
things well the most interesting thing
you know just really quick in the Buns
was you have this high you're going into
this High boom boom
boom all of a sudden turns you got price
rejector here but you have stack SAA
balance right off the high you know to
me that's that's what I consider a very
high percentage trade is you get these
stacked imbalances you know selling
imbalances off the high or buying
imbalances off the low that's what I
like to see but anyway um going
back to the Buns um
yesterday scroll back here
so okay so
anyway here's here where we are um
yesterday morning we have this nice high
here ratio with a Divergence point of
control near the top so you got a couple
things you know ratio Divergence Point
control near the top three things going
for you and get a nice move lower you
know from the 80 area 80 level 79 area
down into the
60s so you know that's nice 15 tick move
there you do get a bounce up come off
again then here you come right back up
near the high you got a price rejector
given a sell signal um a bearish ratio
you come off a little bit over the next
bar come back up into the new highs 6
time is it now 6:30 in the morning if
you remember in the bonds 5 years we
made that high around
um then you start selling off now here
you got the Delta scalper giv a buy it
just goes sideways on you you know
bearish ratio then bullish ratio then a
red bar so again you know as soon as you
get a High signal you get a bearish
signal right afterwards it's probably
not going to be very
effective um then here you got you know
price rejector again with a ratio
bearish ratio bearish ratio the next bar
you just sort of go
sideways single print here test the
level then you get a Delta excuse me
Delta scop given a
buy excuse me I'm going to drink
something Delta scaler given a
buy I'm
sorry it's around the 81 82 level and
what do you do you trade up into the new
highs is again Delta scoper giv that buy
so you know that's about you know we'll
call this whatever we'll call it 82 you
know at least 15 tick there you had
another trade this one didn't work out
um but
earlier okay what was it no I'm getting
confused already the failed Delta scoper
then you got this Delta scoer g a nice
buy so you know you had one loser with
the Delta scoer then you had one nice
winner you know it's not about taking in
and out in and out tons of Trades a day
it's about finding meaningful trades
that you know even when you have loss
like
this okay I mean this is a sign that's
probably not going to work out
immediately then if you're sort of
sitting here waiting waiting you know
you just you take your loss right you're
buying it at 85 starts coming down here
you get out at 79 you get out at 78 you
know you don't get out you know at 72 or
73 rather down here you know when when
it's not working out that's why you know
we draw these lines here so you know if
the trade's not working out by certain
amount of bars get out you know don't
don't wait for it to come all the way
down here wor your stop should just be
right below this the low of the bar
that's giving you the
signal
but you know look for signs that it's
not working out and the first sign that
not working out is this bar you know the
bearish
ratio you know you don't see that here
right what you see is after the bar with
the Delta scalper you see a nice single
print that's what you want to see you
see a nice bullish ratio afterwards and
then the market moves higher that's what
you want to see so you know you take
your six tick loss there but you get
back you know you're buying it here at
82 you cover it back at what I don't
know 94 so you know you lost six ticks
but you just made 12 ticks so you're six
ticks ahead just on that Delta scalper
alone so you know right now we're
trading around
86 talked about the euro currency um let
me see if there's any of
markets
U well I'll talk about British pound I
didn't talk about pound this morning but
you know again it's might as well talk
about it it's again you know I'm not
sure if I'm going to have my room up
today or not um said I still got this
I'm still trying to kick this damn sore
throat I just can't get past it so
anyway we'll go back here this is
yesterday
morning now for what it's worth you know
you got the Delta scalper giv a buy here
this at 2 in the morning you get next
two three bars up Delta surge here
doesn't really work out just sort of
goes sideways on you before it starts
failing but again the Delta scalper is
the more effective uh more effective
signal then you come down to this low
Delta scaler give a buy what happens
this is 6:00 in the
morning you just you it does it does pop
up a little bit and just sort of go
sideways so again you know if you're
getting long here at 6:20 in the morning
and at you know 7:00 it's still trading
around break even get out you you don't
have to be married to this trade until
it's it goes to infinity or goes to your
stop you know if it's not going anywhere
that's a sign to get out and you're
seeing some bearish signs here you're
seeing now you're in this trade you see
bearish Sign Here bearish sign here if
you get out a break even should be happy
then the market Falls
over me again don't let it just
automatically either go to your profit
or go to your stop if you're reading the
order flow and it's not doing what you
expect it to do then you get out simple
as that um simple as that so you're
coming into these lows you don't have
ratios down here you got Divergence it's
almost a ratio 24 it's close one it's
almost close 1.4 it's almost close
Divergence Divergence Divergence had
Delta scalper here giv a buy does make a
new low by two ticks but on this low it
gives you another buy
here and what do you do you come you
know assuming you're getting in
somewhere in this bar you know 85 84 it
moves up to you know the above 129 even
um before it just starts going sideways
on you but you know this was your sign
here this bar when you had a sign here
it probably would have stopped you out
but again it's giving you a second
chance again with another signal right
afterwards and it moves
higher you know it does go higher later
in the day but still I mean you know to
get out somewhere in here is is a decent
exit to get
out and where are we right now excuse me
still got sore throat now we're trading
up near Highs at uh 22 right now nothing
uh you know nothing really telling you
have a Divergence here but other than
that not
much so again you know thanks for
watching this video um I probably will
not have my trading room open
tonight that said uh it should be back
up on Thursday I'm still getting some
stuff sorted
out and it's like we brought five
suitcases on vacation and came back with
five suitcases of dirty laundry but um
and my wife got sick and U my kids are
sick and I'm sick but I'm fine in that
sense but you know if my wife is sick
everything gets uh put on hold because
you know I really got to make sure she
can recover so she can help take care of
the kids but um you know that said I'm
not sure you know if it come to the
trading room tonight and you can't get
in it's because the you know I'm not up
but um hopefully I will have it back up
I should have it back up on Thursday so
again thanks for watching this to learn
more about orderflow visit my website
order flows.com subscribe to my YouTube
channel I try to put out these videos
every day um you know time permitting
it's not always it's not always easy but
um you again I hope you can learn
something and thanks for watching this
and bye-bye